LEED certified building that was a gift
from Henry and Helen pause new junior in
honor of his parents houses the rare and
fine books collection on campus the
collection includes first edition works
by authors such as Copernicus Galileo
Shakespeare and Dickens the highlight of
the collection is one only for excellent
copies of the first printing of the Bill
of Rights the posture center conference
room is a state-of-the-art executive
boardroom with 35 monitors capable of
video conferencing krause Campo a
sculpture garden atop posture Center
provides a landscaped and sculptured
environment creating a vibrant and
comfortable space for students on campus